we've been spending the past few
lectures discussing summaries regularity
lemma and one of the first applications
that we discussed of the regularity
lemma is the triangle removal lemma so
today I want to revisit this topic and
show you a strengthening of the removal
amount for which new regularity
techniques are needed but first we call
the graph removal lemma and the graphs
we move the lemma we have that for every
graph H an epsilon bigger than 0 there
exists some Delta such that if an N
vertex graph has fewer than Delta and
two the number of vertices of H many
copies of H then it can be made h3 by
removing fewer than epsilon and squared
edges even in the case when H is a
triangle when this is called a triangle
removal lemma even in that case
basically the regularity method is more
or less the only way that we in
currently know how to prove this theorem
so we saw this a few lectures ago what I
would like to discuss today is a variant
of this result where instead of
considering copies of H we're now
considering induced copies of age
so this is the induced Graf removal Emma
were the only difference is that
hypothesis is now going to be changed to
induced copies of H and the conclusion
is that you can make the graph induced H
free so let me remind you the difference
between an induced graph sub graph and
the usual sub graph so we say that H is
an induced copy of G induced sub graph
of G if one can obtain H from G by
deleting vertices so you are not allowed
to delete edges but only allowed to
delete vertices so in other words the
for cycle is not an induced sub graph
because well if you select for vertices
you don't generate this for cycle you
get extra edges it is a sub graph but
not an induced sub graph
so the theorem
induced graph removal on master theorem
and let's discuss how we might prove
that theorem question look at question
is why is a stronger than the graph
removal Emma so it's not stronger but we
will see the relationship between the
two of them so I claim that it is more
difficult to do this theorem any more
questions so let's pretend for a second
that okay what everything here is not
quite true
so here's an example if your H for
example if your H is 3 isolated vertices
ok so what is the same we're looking at
copies of H which are 3 isolated
vertices so really you are looking at
triangles in G complement so this is
exactly the triangle removal Emma in the
complement of G but you know you can't
get rid of these guys by removing edges
so we need to make the modification
where instead of removing these edges we
need to both remove and add by adding or
deleting so ok maybe at the same time so
you're allowed to add some edges to be
some edges but in totally change no more
than epsilon and squared edges so this
is sometimes also known as the edit
distance if you allow to change edges ok
so you can I know add I just and delete
edges
any questions about the statement
alright so let's think about how would
you prove this result following that
prove that we did for the triangle
removal lemma so let's pretend that we
go through this proof and think about
what could go wrong so remember in the
application of the removal Emma so the
recipe has three steps the first step we
do a partition okay so we partition
apply similarities regularity lemma do
this partition and the second step is do
a cleaning and the two key things that
happen in the cleaning is we remove
low-density pairs of parts and irregular
pairs and the third step we kind out
once we do the cleaning once we remove
those edges the resulting graph should
be a ch3 because if we're not a ch3 then
by considering the vertex parts where H
lie and applying a counting lemma you
can generate many more copies of H these
were the three main steps in the proof
of the triangle removal lemma so let's
see what goes you know what happens if
we try to apply this strategy to the
induced version I mean the partition you
still do the regularity partition
there's nothing really changes there
okay so let's see in the cleaning step
what happens for low-density pairs well
so now we need to think about not just
low density pairs but also high density
pairs right because in the induced we
think about edges and non edges at the
same time so you might think of our
strategy which is like if the edge
density is less than n there's a less
than epsilon then you remove all those
edges and if the edge density is bigger
than 1 plus epsilon then you add all of
those edges in so this is the natural
generalization of our strategy for
triangle removal lemma
induced setting so so far everything's
still okay but now what would you do for
the irregular pairs that's problematic
previously for triangle removal lemma we
just said if a pairs irregular get rid
of that pair and it will never show up
in the counting stage but that strategy
no longer works right because for
example if your graph H being counted
this year you do the regularity
partition and one of your pairs is
irregular okay so you let's say get rid
of all those edges in between then maybe
you have some embedding of H where you
are going to use the removed edges and
now you don't have a counting lemma you
cannot say I found this copy of H in my
removed changed graph and by the
counting Lama I could get many copies of
H because you have no control over this
irregular pair anymore
so the fact that you have to add and
remove makes it unclear what to do here
and this is a big obstacle in the
application of the regularity lemma to
the induced remove all on our
application any questions about this
obstacle so make sure you understand why
this is an issue otherwise you won't
really appreciate you know what will
happen next
okay so somehow we need to find some
kind of regularity partition to get no
irregular pairs so the question is is
there a way to partition so that there
are no irregular pairs
for those of you who have started your
homework pom long time you realize that
the answer is no so one of the homework
problems is to for you to show that you
know for this specific graph known as
the half graph so there's an example in
homework that's like a half graph you've
seen homework what this graph is you
cannot partition it so that you get rid
of all you regular person irregular
pairs are necessary in the statement of
the regularity lemma so what I want to
show you today is a way to do what's
called a strong regularity lemma in
which you obtain a somewhat different
consequence that will allow you to get
rid of irregular pairs in a more
restricted setting so this is the issue
that you regular pairs
before telling you what this regularity
lemma is I won't to give you a small
generalization of the induced graph
removal lemma or just a different way to
think about the statement and you can
think of it as a colorful version
instead of induced where you have edges
and Nong edges you can also have colored
edges so colorful removal Emma although
this name is not standard okay so
colorful so we talked about graphs
colorful graph removal lemma so for
every K R and epsilon there exists Delta
such that if curly H is a set of our
edge colorings of the complete graph on
little K vertices
okay so edge coloring just means using
our colors to color the edges so there
are no restrictions about what are
allowed what are novel also just a set
if possible or colorings then if the
complete graph
say slightly differently so then every
our edge coloring of the complete graph
on n vertices with fewer than Delta
fraction of its K vertex subsets so K
vertex sub graphs belonging to the
script H ok so every search graph can be
made curly h3 by recoloring so using the
same our colors a fewer than epsilon
fraction so less than epsilon fraction
of the edges of this K so in particular
the version that we just stated the
induced version
so the induced graphic move ulema is the
same as having two colors and H having
one having exactly one red blue coloring
okay the complete graph the same number
of vertices as H so you color read the
edges and blue the non edges for
instance and you're saying I want to
color the a big graphic big complete
graph with red and blue in such a way
that there are very few copies of that
pattern so then I can recolor the red
and blue in a small number of places to
get rid of all such patterns so having a
colored pattern somewhere in your graph
in this complete graph coloring is the
same as having an induced sub graph
yep okay yeah so okay so every our edge
coloring of KN with small number of
patterns can be made it's free by
recoloring a small fraction of the edges
so like in the Triangle removal lemma
every graph with a small number of
triangles can be may try and go free by
removing a small number of edges okay
any other questions all right so this is
a restatement of the removal M of
induced removal Emma with a bit more
generality it's okay if you like this
one more or less but let's talk about
the induced version from now on but the
same proofs that I will talk about also
applies to this version where you have
some more more colors okay so the
variant of the regularity lemma that
we'll need is known as a strong
regularity lemma to state a strong
regularity lemma let me recall a notion
that came up in a proof of similarities
regularity lemma and this was the notion
of an energy and so recall that if you
have a partition denoted P so if this is
a partition of the vertex set of the
graph G and here n is the number of
vertices we defined this notion of
energy
to be this quantity to know the queue
which is basically a squared mean of the
densities between vertex parts
appropriately normalized if the vertex s
do not all have the same size and in the
proof of similarities regularity lemma
there was an important energy increment
step which says that if you have some
partition P that is not epsilon regular
then there exists a refinement Q and
this refinement has the property that Q
has a small number of pieces or not too
large as a function of P so it's bounded
at least in terms of people but also if
P is not epsilon regular then the energy
of Q is significantly larger than the
energy of P so remember this was an
important step in the proof of
regularity lemma
so to state the strong regularity Lama
I will need that notion of energy
and the statement of the strong
regularity lemma if you've never seen
this kind of thing before well seem a
bit intimidating at first because it
involves a whole sequence of parameters
what can use to it so instead of 1
epsilon parameter now you have a
sequence positive epsilon and part of
the strengths of this regularity lemma
is that depending on the application you
have in mind you can make the sequence
go to 0 pretty quickly thereby
increasing the strength of the
regularity lemma so there exists some m
bound which depends only on your epsilon
such that every graph has not just 1 but
now we're going to get a pair of vertex
partitions P and Q with the following
properties
okay so first P refines so Q refines P
so it's a pair of partitions one
refining the other the number of parts
of Q is bounded just like in the usual
regularity lemma the partition P is
epsilon not regular and here is the new
part that's the most important one Q is
very epsilon regular so it's not just
epsilon not regular its epsilon sub the
number of parts of P regular so you
should think of this as extremely
regular because you get to choose what
the sequence of epsilon is and finally
the energy difference between P and Q is
not too big
this is the statement of the strong
regularity lemma it produces for you not
just one partition but a pair of
partitions and in this pair of
partitions you have one partition P
which is similar to the one that we
obtain from similarly circular key lemma
is some epsilon not regular but we also
get a refinement Q and this Q is
extremely regular think that is P the Q
is an extremely regular refinement of P
any questions about the statement of the
strong regularity lemma so the sequence
of Epsilon gives you flexibility on how
to apply it but let's see how to prove
it and the proof is you know what once
you understand how this works is
conceptually it's pretty short but let
me do it slowly so that we can
appreciate this sequence of Epsilon and
the idea is that we will repeatedly
apply similarities regularity start with
the regularity lemma we'll apply it
repeatedly to generate a sequence of
partitions so first let me remind you a
statement of similar destroy clarity
lemma this is slightly different from
the one that we stated but comes out of
the same proof so for every epsilon
there exists some M naught which depends
on epsilon such that for every partition
P naught so starting with some partition
okay so actually let me start with just
P so if you start with person partition
the vertex set of G there exists a
refinement P prime of P into at most
okay so the refinement has is such that
with each part P we find into at most
and not parts such that P Prime the new
partition is epsilon regular so this is
a statement of similarity regularity
lemma that we will apply repeatedly so
in the version that we've seen before we
would start with a trivial partition and
applying refinements repeatedly in the
proof to get a partition into a bounded
number of parts such that the final
partition is epsilon regular but instead
in the proof of the regularity lemma if
you start with not the trivial partition
but start with a given partition and run
the exact same proof you find this
consequence except now you can guarantee
that the final partition is a refinement
of the one that you are given so let's
apply this statement and we obtain a
sequence of partitions of G the vertex
set of G starting with P not being a
trivial partition
and so on such that each partition each
P sub I plus one refines the previous
one and such that each P sub I plus 1 is
epsilon sub P sub I regular so you apply
the regularity lemma with parameter
based on the number of parts you
currently have apply to the current
partition you get a finer partition
that's extremely regular and you also
know that the number of parts of the new
partition is bounded in terms of the
previous partition
all right any questions so far so now we
get the sequence of partitions you can
keep on doing this so G could be
arbitrarily large but eventually we will
be able to obtain the last condition
here which is the only thing that is
missing so far so since the energy is
bounded between zero and one there
exists some I at most one over epsilon
naught such that the energy goes up by
less than epsilon naught because
otherwise your energy will exceed one
so now let's set P to be this P I and Q
to be this the refinement the next term
in the partition and what we find is
that the okay so then then you have
basically all the conditions so P is
epsilon not regular because it is
epsilon but previous term which is most
epsilon not regular and you have this
one as well and this one as well and we
want to show that the number of parts of
Q is bounded and that's basically
because each time there was a bound on
the number of parts which depends only
on the regularity parameters and you're
repeating that bound bound the number of
times so so Q yes okay so it's bounded
it's bound as a function of the sequence
of Epsilon right this infinite vector of
epsilon so it is a bounded number
you only iterating this bound bound the
number of times and that finishes the
proof any questions
alright it might be somewhat mysterious
to you right now why we do this
so we'll get to the application in a
second but for now I just want to
comment a bit on the balance of course
the band's depend on what epsilon eyes
do you use and typically you want the
epsilon eyes to decrease with more parts
that you have and with almost all
reasonable applications of this
regularity lemma the strong regularity
lemma so for example with epsilon I
being some epsilon divided by let's say
I plus 1 or any polynomial of the ice
you can even let it decay quicker than
Atlas well you see basically what
happens is that you are applying this am
not bound
I am not applied in succession 1 over
epsilon times and in the regularity
lemma we saw that the M naught that
comes out of ephemeral d-squad
regularity lemma is the power function
power function as a power of I is
defined to be the exponential function
iterated I times of course I'm being
somewhat loose here with the exact
dependence but you get the idea that now
we want to apply the tower function I
times
instead of iterating the exponential
items now you iterate at our function I
times and are some of your laughing this
is an incredibly large number it's even
larger than the tower function okay so
in literature especially around the
regularity lemma this function where you
iterate at our function l I x is given
the name
wowser as saying wow this is a huge
number so it's a step up in the acraman
hierarchy so if you repeat the wowser
function r times you move up one ladder
in the Ackermann hierarchy and this
hierarchy of rapidly growing functions
but the only case it's bounded and
that's good enough for us any questions
so far
yeah
yes Oh questions what do you call wowzer
iterated I'm not aware of a standard
name for that actually even the name
wowzer somehow is very common in the
common networks community but I think
most people outside this community will
not recognize this work any more
questions so another way is that you
step up in a command hierarchy so it's
enumerated 1 2 3 4 you know if you keep
going up all right another remark about
this strong regularity lemma is that it
will be convenient for us actually
somewhat more essential compared to our
previous applications to make the parts
equitable so P and Q equitable and
basically the parts are such that all
the the partitions are such that all the
parts have basically the same number of
vertices so I won't make it precise but
you can do it you know it's not too hard
to do it and you can do this you can
prove it similar to how I described how
to modify the proof of the regularity
lemma yes I won't belabor that point but
we'll use the equitable version alright
so how does one use this regularity
lemma let me state a corollary and let
me call this a corollary start because
you actually need to do some work to get
it to follow from the strong regularity
lemma but the corollary is the version
that we will apply if you start with a
decreasing sequence of epsilon then
there exists a delta such that the
following is true
every end vertex graph has an equitable
vertex partition call it you I through V
okay
and a subset WI of each VI such that
following properties hold first all the
WS are fairly large at least constant
proportion of the total vertex set
between every pair of WI WJ it is
epsilon sub-k regular and this is the
point I want to emphasize so here there
are no irregular pairs anymore so it is
every no you regular pairs between the
Wis and also we need to include the case
when I equals to J as well so each WI is
regular with itself and furthermore the
edge densities between that these are
similar to the extensity is between the
corresponding w's and here it is for
most pairs for all but at most epsilon K
square pairs
epsilon not
yeah I'm most Epsilon not any questions
about the statement all right so let me
show you how you could deduce the
corollary from the strong regularity
lemma
so first let me draw you a picture so
here you have a regularity partition and
so these are your V's and inside each V
I find a W such that if I look at the
edge sets between pairwise Bruce sets
including the blue sets with themselves
it is always very regular and also the
edge densities between the blue sets is
mostly very similar to the edge density
between their ambient white sets
okay so let me say a few words I won't
go into too many details about how you
might deduce this corollary from the
strong regularity lemma so first let me
do something which is slightly simpler
which is to not yet require that it blue
sets W eyes are regular with themselves
so without requiring this is regular so
we can obtain DWIs by picking a uniform
random part of the finer partition Q
inside each part P in the strong
regularity lemma so you have the strong
regularity lemma which produces for you
a pair of partitions like that so it
produces for you pair of partitions and
what we will do is to take one of these
guys as my W pick one of these guys I
ran them and pick one of those guys at
random because W is so extremely regular
most of these pairs will be regular so
with high probability you will not
encounter any irregular pairs if you
pick the Q's add if you pick the W's
randomly as parts of Q so that's the key
point here we're using that Q is
extremely regular
oh the WI double J regular for all I not
equal to J with high probability but the
other thing that we would like is that
the edge densities between the WS are
similar to those between the vs and for
that we will use this condition about
their energies being very similar to
each other
so the third consequence see is it's a
consequence of the energy bound because
recall that in our proof of the semele
regularity lemma there was an
interpretation of the energy as the
second moment of a certain random
variable which we called Z and using
that interpretation I can write down
this expression like that where here
assuming for simplicity that Q is
completely equitable so all the parts
have exactly the same size Z of Q is
defined to be the edge density between
VI and VJ for random IJ so this is a
random variable Z okay so you pick pair
of parts uniformly or maybe with some
weights if they're not exactly equal and
you evaluate the edge density so this
energy difference is the difference
between the second moments and because Q
is a refinement of P
it is the case that this difference of
l2 norms
equal to the second moment of the
difference of the random variables so we
saw a version of this earlier when we
were discussing variance in the context
of the proof of the similarity
regularity lemma here it's basically the
same you can either look at this
inequality part by part of V or if you
like to you know be a bit more abstract
then this is actually a case of
Pythagorean theorem if you view these as
course vectors you know certain vector
space then you have some orthogonality
so you have this sum of squares identity
okay where does Part A come from so Part
A we want the parts the W ice to be not
too small but that comes from a bound on
the number of parts of Q
okay so so far this more or less proofs
the corollary except for that we
simplified our lives by requiring just
that I not equal to J the V I V J's are
regular but in the statement up there we
also want the V ice that so the W ice to
be regular with themselves which will be
important for application so I will
explain how to do that
and part of the reason is that this is
also one of the homework problems so
your money the homework problems on
problem set three you are asked to prove
that every graph has a subset of
vertices that is a constant least
constant proportion such that it is
regular with itself and the methods you
use there will be applicable to handle
the situation over here as well so
putting all of these ingredients
together we get the corollary whereby
you have this picture you have this
partition I don't even require the VIS
to be regular that doesn't matter
anymore all that matters is that between
the W ice they are very regular and that
there are no irregular parts between
these W ice and now we'll be able to go
back to the induced graph removal em up
where previously we had an issue with a
block with the existence of irregular
pairs in the usual similarity regularity
partition and now we have a tool to to
get around that so next we will see how
to execute this proof but at this point
hopefully you already see it outlined
because well you no longer need to worry
about you know this thank you so let's
take quick break
any questions so far yes okay so the
question was there was a step where we
were looking at some expectations of
squares and so why was that identity
true if okay so if you look back to the
proof of some radius regularity lemma we
already saw instance of that inequality
in the computation of the variance so
please so you know that the variance of
X on one hand it is equal to where mu is
the mean of X and on the other hand in a
sequel to this quantity okay so you
agree with this formula and and you can
expand it to prove it and that the thing
that the question that you raised
basically you can prove by looking at
this formula part by part okay good any
more questions
so let's now prove the induced graph
removal MO and we'll follow the
regularity partition but with a small
twist that instead of using some Reddy's
regularity lemma we will use that
corollary up there so let's prove the
induced graph removal lemma so the three
steps first we do partition so let's
suppose you have a okay so we suppose G
is like above you have a few very few
copies induced copies of H let's apply
the corollary to get a partition of the
vertex set of G into K parts and inside
each part I have a w satisfying the
following properties that each WI WJ is
regular with the following parameter
which will come out of later when we
need to use the counting lemma but it's
some number but don't worry too much
about it so here I'm going to okay so
let's say H as H vertices
so between wiw J it is this regular so
we actually have not yet use the full
strength of the corollary where I can
make the regularity even depend on K
okay so we will not need that here but
we'll need it in a later application so
the exponent is H okay so other
properties are that the intensities
between the V eyes and the W eyes do not
differ by more than epsilon over two for
all but a small fraction so epsilon K
squared over two pairs and finally the
sizes of the Wis are at least Delta
naught times n they were Delta naught
depends only on epsilon epsilon and H
okay
great
this is the partition step so now let's
do the cleaning in the cleaning step
basically we're not going to I mean
there's no longer an issue
irregular pairs if we only look at the w
i's so we just need to think about the
low-density pairs or whatever the
corresponding analog is and what happens
here is that for every pi less than j
crucially including when I equals to J
if the edge density is between the W's
is too small then we remove all edges
between VI and VJ and if X density
between the W eyes is too big then we
remove all edges so we add all edges
between VI and VJ
yep so how many edges do we end up
adding or removing so the total number
of edges added or removed from G this in
this case right so if the edges density
in G between the VIS and VJs is also
very small then you do not remove very
many edges most pairs of VI and VJ have
that property so you tidy up what kind
of errors you can get from here and
there and you find that the total number
of edges that are added or removed from
G is less than let's say epsilon and
squared maybe you need an extra factor
of 2 but it's a punk changing some
constant factors it's less than epsilon
N squared so this is some small details
you can work out here we're using so how
is the edge density between VI and VJ we
did it at W I and W J or for most pairs
of I and J they're very similar and
there's a small fraction of them that
are not similar but then you lump
everything in to this bound over here
so maybe I need to let me just pull up
to here just to be safe all right
so we debated a very small number of
edges and now we want to show that the
graph that is resulted from this
modification does not have any induced H
sub graphs final step chanting so
suppose there were any induced H left
after the modification so I want to show
that in fact there must be a lot of HS
induced HS originally in the graph there
by contradicting the hypothesis so
suppose okay so where does this induced
H sit well you have this the B's and
inside the B's you have the W's
so suppose my H is that graph for
illustration and in particular I have a
non edge okay so I have an edge and I
also have an on edge so between these
two as the knowledge so suppose you find
a copy of H in the cleaned up graph
working that cleaned up this copy of H
so suppose you find that here the claim
now is that if this copy of H existed
here then I must be able to find many
such copies of H in the corresponding
yellow parts because between the yellow
parts you have regularity and you also
have the right kinds of densities
because if they didn't have the right
kind of density we would have cleaned it
up all right so that's the idea
if you had a copy of this H somewhere
then i zoom into the yellow parts zoom
into this w s-- and I find lots of
copies of H in between the W's okay so
suppose let me write this down so
suppose the little V the vertices lies
the okay so I'm just indexing we're
little VD lives a little veal icing pick
the sub CV for some fee which sends the
vertices of h21 to okay so now we apply
counting lemma to embed induced copies
of H in G where the vertex V in H is
mapped to a vertex in a corresponding W
and we would like to know that there are
lots of such copies and the counting
lemma or rather some variant but you can
actually read the counting lined up with
their last time and view it as a
multi-part I'd version apply this so far
part apart so we find that the number of
such induced copies is within a small
error so within for that regularity
parameter
multiplied by the number of edges of H
which we already cancelled out
multiplied by the product of these W is
within this error of what you would
suspect if you naively multiply the edge
densities together along with the vertex
densities so these factors are for the
for the edges that you want to embed and
then I also need to multiply the
densities for the non edges so one minus
these edge densities so one way you can
think of it is just considered a
compliment in G I so consider the
compliment of G to get this version here
and then finally the product of the
vertex set sizes
and point is that this is not a small
number so the number hence the number of
induced copies of H in G is at least on
the water of Wow okay so it's at least
some number which is basically this guy
over here epsilon over 4 raised to I
mean all of these are constants so
that's the point all of these guys are
constants - so here is a main term and
then the error term and then the product
of these vertex set sizes and we saw
that each vertex set is not too small so
you have lots of induced copies of H and
G yep
okay so can you repeat your question
okay so question how do we deal with the
oppa epsilon over two pairs so that
comes up in the cleaning step in what I
wrote in red in dealing with the number
of total edges that are added or removed
so think about how many edges are added
or removed in this non exceptional pairs
the number of edges that are added or
removed so in okay so in let's just
think about added edges so if the
density of V is controlled by that of W
then the number of edges added or
removed in that case from all such pairs
along with yeah so you have epsilon and
squared edges changed on the other hand
if this is not true then you only have
epsilon K squared such pairs IJ for
which this cannot be true so you also
only have at most epsilon and squared
and just added or removed in such cases
so you switch number zero top board ah
good so asking about this number so that
should have been - yes okay it's
question you don't see K appearing
anywhere so the K in the corollary do
you mean okay so that hasn't come up yet
so it comes up implicitly because we
need to lower bound these sizes of these
W so so if you had so this is partly why
we need a bound on the number of parts
but it is true that we do not need
epsilon K depending on K in this
application yet I will mention a
different application in a second where
you do need that K okay right so the
number of induced H in G is at least
this amount so that's a small lie you
need to maybe consider some this is a
number of homomorphic well actually no
we're okay nevermind so so you can set
Delta to be this quantity here and then
that finishes the proof so you have lots
of induced copies of H in your graph
which contradicts the hypothesis so that
finishes the proof of the induced
removal EMA and basically the proof is
the same as the usual graph removal EMA
except that now we need some
strengthened regularity lemma which
allows us to get rid of irregular parts
but in a more restricted setting because
we saw you cannot completely get rid of
irregular parts
any questions yes so I want to address
the question of why did I state this
corollary in this more general form of a
decrease in sequence of Epsilon
oh so first of all you know with strong
regularity lemma the strength it's
sometimes always nice to it's always
nice to state it with this extra
strength because there it's the right
way to think about these types of
theorems that the regularity on the
parts depends you can make it it depend
on the number of parts so that you get
much stronger control on the regularity
but there also some applications for
example whether I will stay next an
application where you do need that kind
of strength so here is what's known as
an infinite remove all m up here we have
not just a single pattern or a finite
number of patterns we want to get rid of
but now we have infinitely many patterns
so for every curly H which is a possibly
infinite set of grass the grass
themselves are always finite so but this
may be an infinite list and an epsilon
parameter there exists an H naught and a
delta positive parameter such that every
N vertex graph with at most Delta 2 less
than Delta be to the H induced copies of
H for every H in this family with fewer
than it's not vertices
so every graph with this property can be
made
curly H free so means free up induced
curly h free by adding or removing fewer
than epsilon and squared edges okay so
now instead of a single pattern you have
an possibly infinite set up induced
patterns and I want to make your graph
curly H free induced curly h free and
the theorem is that if there is some
there exist some finite bound it's not
such that if you have few copies so for
all the patterns up to that point then
you can do what you need to do okay so
let's take some time to even digest a
statement but it's somehow infinite
inversions the correct infinite version
of the removal lemma if you have
infinitely many patterns that you need
to remove and I claim the proof is
actually more or less the same proof as
that one that we did here except now you
need to take your epsilon case as in its
corollary to depend on K you need to in
some way look ahead in this infinite
pattern so here improve this epsilon
came from corollary depends K and also
it depends on your family of patterns H
all right
finally I want to mention a perspective
a computer science perspective on this
on this removal ms that we've been
discussing so far and that's in the
context of something called property
testing and basically we would like an
efficient special meaning fast a
randomized algorithm to distinguish
graphs that are triangle free from those
that are epsilon far from triangle free
we're being epsilon far from triangle
free means that you need to change more
than epsilon and squared edges here and
this as usual the number of vertices to
make triangle free to make the graph
triangle freak so the distance to edit
distance is more than epsilon away from
being triangle free so you know somebody
gives you a very large graph think n is
very large you cannot search through
every pair every triple vertices that's
too expensive but you want some way to
test if a graph is triangle free vs.
very far away from being triangle free
so there's a very simple randomized
algorithm to do this which is to just
try randomly sample a random triple
vertices and check if it's a triangle
you do this and just to make our life
you know a bit more secure let's try it
some larger number of times so some C of
epsilon some constant number of times
and if you find a triangle if okay so if
you don't find a triangle then we return
that it is triangle free otherwise we
return that it was epsilon far from
triangle free so that's the algorithm so
it's very intuitive algorithm but why
does it work so we want to know that
indeed somebody gives you one of these
two possibilities you run that algorithm
you can succeed with high probability
question
okay so let's talk about why this works
so theorem for every epsilon there
exists to see such that algorithm
succeeds with probability bigger than
2/3 and 2/3 can be any number any number
that you like because you can always
repeat it to boost that constant
probability okay so there are two cases
FG is triangle free then it always
succeeds you will never find this
triangle and it would return triangle
free on the other hand if G is epsilon
far from triangle free then triangle
remove all Emma tells us that G has lots
of triangles Delta N cubed triangles so
if we simple C being let's say 1 over
delta x delta here is a function of
epsilon from the triangle removal lemma
so we find that the probability that the
algorithm fails is at most
so you have lots of triangles so very
likely you will hit one of these
triangles so the probability that
algorithm fails is at most 1 minus Delta
and cubed divided by total number of
triples raised to 1 over Delta and this
is one - most 1 - 6 Delta raised to 1
over Delta and it's at most e to the
minus 6 so less than 1/3 in particular
so this algorithm succeeds with high
probability you know how big of a see do
you need well that depends on the
triangle removal mo so it's a constant
it's a constant does not depend on the
size of the graph but it's a Const it's
a large constant because we saw in a
proof of regularity lemma that it can be
very large that's done you know this
theorem here it's basically the same as
a triangle removal lemma so it's highly
non-trivial that it is true even though
the algorithm is extremely naive and
simple I just want to finish off what
one more thing instead of testing for
triangle freeness you can ask what other
properties can you test so which graph
properties are testable in The Fault in
that sense so distinguishing something
which has the property so P versus far
Epsilon far from this property P and and
you have this tester which is you sample
some number of vertices so this is
called the oblivious tester
so you sample k vertices and you try to
see if it has that property okay so
there's a class of properties called
hereditary so hereditary properties are
properties that are closed under vertex
deletion and these properties are lots
of properties that you've seen are of
this form so for example being a ch3
it's this form being planar so this one
being induced a ch3 so it's form being 3
colorable being perfect they're all
examples of hereditary properties
properties that if your graph is 3
colorable you take out some vertices
it's still 3 colorable and all the
discussions that we've done so far in
particular the infinite removal Emma if
you phrase it in the form of property
testing given the above discussion it
implies that every hereditary property
it's testable so it's 1 in fact it's
testable in the above sense with a
one-sided error using oblivious tester
one-sided error means that if it's up
there if it's triangle free then it
always succeeds so here one of the cases
always succeeds and the reason is that
you can characterize a hereditary
property by a curly H induced H free for
some curry H namely you're putting
everything into H that do not have this
property
this is a possibly infinite set of
graphs and that completely characterizes
this credit or property and if you read
out the infinite removal lemma
it says precisely you know using above
this interpretation that you have a
property testing algorithm